OOA is a requirements analysis technique developed by Abbott and
Booch in the 1980s. It concentrates on modeling real-world objects based on
their descriptions in natural language to produce an object analysis model.
We will express these models primarily using UML class model diagrams.
Object oriented analysis pays primary attention to the objects with which
a problem's concerned. Prior to OOA, on the other hand,
the predominant method of analysis is analysis and design. With structure
design, also called functional decomposition. In contrast with OOA,
functional decomposition was concerned with the functions that the solution,
that the solution was required to provide rather than the objects.